today we're going to show you a
technique on how to stop
tinnitus or you can pronounce it
tinnitus now this technique was not
developed by me it was developed by a dr
j
stratum and i did a video on this about
four or five years ago yet many people
have never seen it and they can't find
it but i want to quickly just share a
few of the success stories
from this video and these are just right
in the comments so check this out the
first comment
i've had ringing the ears for years this
morning was real bad and i just found
this video i immediately tried it
instant relief it's not completely gone
but i do feel better next one i've had
problems with this for years having
worked for many years as a musician with
loud groups i rated my right ear as a
five before the experiment and after
four repetitions i could not perceive
any difference however after eight reps
the volume of tinnitus in my right ear
has diminished somewhat and the top
searing end of the pitch has gone
completely gives me hope thanks for the
video here's another one i've had
ringing in my ears for at least 10 years
i swear
i went from a seven or an eight to a two
or three after doing this routine three
times all right here's another one
oh my god i've been having 24 7 ringing
for three plus years this lesson the
ringing after the fourth round gonna
keep it going thanks all right and
here's this one more that i have to
share with you
i could honestly cry this actually
helped me i was just about to lose my
mind and start panicking and it actually
went away thank you so much all right so
very simply what is tinnitus well it's a
perception of hearing a noise when there
isn't any noise and so the latin word
for tinnitus
means to ring and the latin word for
noise
means nausea disgust discomfort hurting
injury
and damage
so tonight this can be actually
devastating if you're constantly hearing
this high pitch ringing or sound in your
ear and it can go beyond a minor
annoyance and be a major situation that
could literally just destroy your life
so let me explain this technique
tinnitus really is not a problem in the
ear itself
it's a problem within the nervous system
that connects to the brain so you have
these receptors in your ears
that are receiving sound waves and then
your ear
converts those vibrations into
electrical impulses that are then
interpreted by the brain as certain
pitches so there's a main nerve that
connects the inner ear to the part of
the brain that interprets sound called
the auditory cortex and that nerve is
called the eighth cranial nerve so i'm
going to show you how to reset the nerve
and turn off the noise now i did modify
this technique slightly okay
but i put a link down below of the
person who developed a technique so you
can get more data if you want but what
you're going to be doing is you're going
to be tapping with your fingers you're
going to take your index finger over
your middle finger okay
i'm not going to flip you off but and
you're going to be like
snapping them like this okay
on the back part of your
skull now there's a little ridge in the
back part of your skull
that's called the occiput and if we take
a line from your ear and draw it right
in the back part okay that's where
you're going to be tapping
okay so you're going to take your
fingers
and you're going to
you know tap like like this you're going
to snap your fingers down and tap the
back of your skull and so what you're
going to do is you're going to send
signals into the eighth range nerve to
send it into the brain so apparently
there is some short circuiting going on
or a glitch in the brain's computer but
before you do this please please please
rate from a scale from 0 to 10. 10 being
a major major problem
0 being no problem at all so go ahead
and do that right now in fact put that
in the comments section and then after
you do this technique
then re-rate it so i can see your
results and so can everyone else so now
that you have a before number you start
tapping you're going to just tap for 20
times okay 20 times
so pause the video right now as you tap
the back part of your skull 20 times
okay now the next step is you're just
going to re-rate that perception of that
noise
okay so did it decrease from the
original number go ahead and write that
down so basically you're going to be
doing the series of tapping motions in
the back of your skull
and then re-rating the intensity
of the noise roughly eight times or
eight cycles
because as you read in one of the
success stories someone didn't see
improvement until they've done it eight
times so eight times of 20 taps now if
you've seen any improvement doing this
okay you're going to continue to do this
every day
a few times a day until it's a zero but
let's say for some reason you don't see
improvement well then there could be
some other cause for this because it
doesn't work on everyone and the other
thing i'm going to recommend to try if
this does not work
is to find a product called benfotamine
i don't have a brand to recommend but
you want to take a hundred and fifty
milligrams
three times a day benfotamine is a fat
soluble
vitamin b1
that helps to penetrate the brain and
sometimes people can develop um
problems from insulin resistance okay
because they have a problem with
their nervous system because this
condition affects the nerves okay and it
can also affect the autonomic nerves the
peripheral nerves in your feet and your
hands as well as the nerve in the inner
ear so ben photomine can sometimes help
if you have the condition of insulin
resistance and that's the root cause so
anyway try this technique comment down
below to see how it helped you so we can
all
read the success stories and if you have
not seen my video on benfotamine or b1 i
put it up right here check it out